PROFESSOR: The law
of large numbers
gives a precise formal statement
of the basic intuitive idea
that underlies
probability theory,
and in particular, our
interest in random variables
and their expectations--
their means.
So let's begin by asking
what the mean means.
Why are we so interested
in it, for example.
If you roll a fair
die, with faces one
through six, the mean value,
its expected value is 3 and 1/2.
And you'll never roll
3 and 1/2 because there
is no 3 and 1/2 face.
So why do we care about what
this mean is if we're never
going to roll it?
And the answer is
that we believe
that after many
rolls, if we take
the average of the numbers
that show on the dice,
that average is going
to be near the mean.
The mean is going to
be near 3 and 1/2.
Let's look at an even
more basic example.
If it's a fair die, the
probability of rolling a six,
as with any other
number, is one sixth.
And the very meaning of the fact
that the probability of rolling
a six is one sixth
is that we expect
that if you roll a lot of times,
if you roll about n times,
the fraction of sixes is
going to be around n/6.
The fraction of six is
going to be about one sixth.
Of n rolls, you'll
get about n/6 6s.
That's almost the definition--
or the intuitive idea
behind what we mean when
we assign probability
to some outcome.
It's that if we
did it repeatedly,
the fraction of
times that it came up
would be equal to
its probability--
or at least closely equal
to it in the long run.
So let's look at what
Jacob Bernoulli, who
is the discoverer of the
law of large numbers,
had to say on the subject.
He was born in 1659
and died in 1705.
And his famous book, The Art
of Guessing-- Ars Conjectandi--
was actually published
posthumously by his cousin.
And Bernoulli says,
"Even the stupidest man--
by some instinct
of nature per se
and by no previous instruction--
this is truly amazing--
knows for sure that the more
observations that are taken,
the less the danger will be
of straying from the mark."
All right.
What does he mean?
Well, it's what we
said a moment ago.
If you roll the fair die n times
and the probability of a roll
is a sixth, then the average
number of sixes, which
is the number of sixes
rolled divided by n,
we believe intuitively
that that number
is going to approach one sixth
as n approaches infinity.
That's what Bernoulli is saying,
that everybody understands
that they intuitively
are sure of it.
And who knows how
they figured that out.
But that's what everyone thinks.
And he might be right.
Now of course, when you're doing
this experiment of rolling n
times and counting
the number of sixes
and seeing if the fraction
is close to a sixth,
you might be unlucky.
And it's possible that
you'd get an average that
actually was way off one sixth.
But that would be unlucky.
And the question is,
how unlikely is it
to be that you'd get a
fraction of sixes that
wasn't really close to a sixth?
And with the law
of large numbers
is getting a grip on
that, and in fact,
subsequently, we'll get a
more even quantitative grip
on it, which will be
crucial for applications
in sampling and
hypothesis testing.
But let's go on.
So let's look at some actual
numbers which I calculated.
And if you roll a die n times,
where n is 6, 60, 600, 1,200,
3,000 or 6,000, the
probability that you're
going to be within 10% of
the expected number of sixes
is given here.
So it turns out, of
course, that in order
to be within 10--
if you're going
to roll six times,
the only way to be
within 10% of the one expected
six that you should roll,
is to roll exactly
one six in six tries.
And the probability
of that is about 40%,
0.4 as you can check
yourself easily.
Then it turns out that
if you roll 60 times,
the probability of being-- the
expected number in 60 rolls
is going to be 10.
So the probability of there
being within 10% of 10,
or nine to 11 sixes is 0.26.
And likewise, the
probability of there
being within 10% of 100, which
is the expected number of sixes
when you roll 600
times, is 0.72.
And so on until
finally the probability
of being within
10% of 1,000, which
is the expected number when
you roll 6,000 times, that
is between 900 and 1,100
sixes in 6,000 rolls,
is 0.999-- triple nines.
In fact, it's a
little bit bigger.
So it's really only
about one chance in 1,000
that your number of sixes
won't fall in that interval,
within 10% of the
expected number.
Well, suppose I ask
for a tighter tolerance
and I'd like to know what's the
probability of being within 5%.
Well first of all,
notice of course,
that as the number
of rolls get larger,
the probability of being
in this given interval
is getting higher and higher,
which is what Bernoulli said
and what we intuitively believe.
The more rolls,
the more likely you
are to be close to
what you expect.
If you tighten the
tolerance, of course,
then the probabilities
wind up getting smaller
that you'll do so well.
So if you want to be within 5%
of the average in six rolls,
it means you still have to roll
exactly one sixth, which means
the probability is still 0.4.
But if you're trying
to be within 5%
of the expected number
10 and 60 rolls,
meaning between five
and 15, that probability
is only 0.14 compared
to the probability
of 0.26 of being within 10%.
And if we jump down here,
say, to 3,000 rolls,
the probability of being
within 10% of 500, which
is the expected number in 3,000
rolls, within 10% is 0.98.
But within being
within 5% of 500,
it's 0.78, or about
a little over 3/4.
So what does that tell us?
Well, it means that if
you rolled 3,000 times
and you did not get within 10%
of the expected number 500,
that is you did not get in
the interval between 450
and 556 sixes, you
can be 98% confident
that your die is loaded.
It's not weighted one
sixth to show a six.
And similarly, if you did not
get within 425 and 525 sixes
in 3,000 rolls, you can be 78%
sure that your die is loaded.
And this is exactly why
the law of large numbers
is so important to us because
it allows us to do an experiment
and then assess whether
what we think is true
is verified by the outcome
that we got in this experiment.
All right.
Let's go on to see
what else Bernoulli was
concerned with in his time.
"It certainly remains
to be inquired
whether after the
number of observations
has been increased, the
probability of obtaining
the true ratio finally exceeds
any given degree of certainty,
or whether the problem
has, so to speak,
its own asymptote-- that
is, whether some degree
of certainty is given,
which one can never exceed."
Now, that's 17th century English
that may be a little bit hard
to parse.
So let's translate it
into math language.
What is it that
Bernoulli is asking?
So what Bernoulli
means is that he
wants to think about
taking a random variable R
with an expectation
or mean of mu.
And he wants to make n
trial observations of R
and take the average
of those observations
and see how close
they are to mu.
All right.
What is making n trial
observations mean?
Well, formally, the way we're
going to capture it is we're
going to think of having
a bunch of mutually
independent, identically
distributed random variables
R1 through Rn.
This phrase "independent,
identically distributed"
comes up so often that there's
a standard abbreviation i.i.d
random variables.
So we're going to
have n of them.
And think of those
as being the n
observations that we make
of a given random variable
R. So R1 through Rn each have
exactly the same distribution
as R. And they're
mutually independent.
And again, since they have
identical distributions,
they all have the same mean,
mu, as the random variable R
that we were trying
to investigate.
So we model n
independent trials,
repeated trials, by saying that
we have n random variables that
are i.i.d.
OK.
Now, what Bernoulli's
proposing is
that you take the average
of those n random variables.
So you take the sum of R1, R2,
up through Rn, and divide by n.
That's the average value.
Call that A sub n-- the average
of the n observations or the n
rolls.
And Bernoulli's question
is, is this average probably
close to the mean,
mu, if n is big?
What exactly does that mean?
Probably close to mu
means that the probability
that the distance between
the average and mu
is less than or equal to delta.
Is what?
So delta is talking
about how close you are.
Delta is a parameter.
We expect it's got
to be positive.
Think of whatever
"close" means to you.
Does it mean 0.1?
Does it mean 0.01?
What amount would persuade
you that the average was
close to what it ought to be?
And we ask then,
whether the distance
between the average and
the mean is close-- less
than or equal to delta.
And Bernoulli
wants to know, what
is the probability of that?
And what it goes on to
say is, "Therefore this
is the problem which I
now set forth and make
known after I have pondered
over it for 20 years.
Both its novelty and its
very great usefulness,
coupled with its
great difficulty,
can exceed in weight and value
all the remaining chapters
of this thesis."
Now, Bernoulli was right
on about the usefulness
of this result, at least
in its quantitative form.
And at the time, it was really
pretty difficult for him.
It took him like 200 pages
to complete his proof
in Ars Conjectandi.
Nowadays, we are going
to do it in about
a lecture worth of material.
And you'll be seeing that in
some subsequent video segment.
So that's what happens with
350 years to tune up a result.
What took 200 pages then,
now takes 10 or less pages.
In fact, if it was
really concise,
it could be done in three pages.
All right.
So again, coming back
to Bernoulli's question.
Bernoulli's question is,
what is the probability
that the distance between
the average and the mean
is less than or equal to delta
as you take more and more
tries, as n goes to infinity?
And Bernoulli's
answer to the question
is, that the probability is 1.
That is, if you want to have
a certain degree of certainty
of being close to
the mean, if you
take enough trials you can
be as certain as you want,
that you'll be as
close as you want.
And that is called the
weak law of large numbers.
And it's one of the basic,
transcendent rules and theorems
of probability theory.
It's usually stated
in the other way,
as that the limit of the
probability that the average is
a distance away from
the mean delta is zero.
It's the probability that
it's extremely unlikely.
It can be as
unlikely as you want
to make it that it's
more than any given
tolerance from the mean, if
you take a large enough number
of trials.
Now, in this form, it's
not yet really useful.
This is a romantic
qualitative limiting result.
And to really use it, you need
to know something or other
about the rate at which it
approaches the limit, which
is what we're going to be
seeing in a subsequent video.
And in fact, the
proof of this is
going to follow easily from
the Chebyshev inequality
bound and variance
properties when
we go about trying to get
the quantitative version that
explains the rate at which
the limit is approached.